Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Qui dove il mare luccica,
e tira forte il vento.
Su una vecchia terrazza,
davanti al Golfo di Sorrento.
Un uomo abbraccia una ragazza
dopo che aveva pianto.
Poi si schiarisce la voce,
e ricomincia il canto.
Te voglio bene assaje...
ma tanto tanto bene sai.
È una catena ormai...
che scioglie il sangue dint''e vene, sai.
Vide le luci in mezzo al mare,
pensò alle notti là in America.
Ma erano solo le lampare
nella bianca scia di un'elica.
Sentì il dolore nella musica,
si alzò dal pianoforte.
Ma quando vide la luna
uscire da una nuvola,
gli sembrò più dolce anche la morte.
Ma sì, è la vita che finisce.
Ma lui non ci pensò poi tanto.
Anzi, si sentiva già felice
e ricominciò il suo canto.
Tutti insieme.
Te voglio bene assaje.
Ma tanto, tanto bene sai.
È una catena, ormai,
che scioglie il sangue dint' 'e 'vvene,
dint' 'e 'vvene sai.
Te voglio bene assaje,
ma tanto, tanto bene, tanto bene sai.
È una catena ormai...
che scioglie il sangue
dint'e 'vvene sai.
Grazie. (Applausi)
Grazie, io sono Frida -
Era un sol.
C'è ancora, eh.
Dicevo, io sono Frida Bollani Magoni.
Questa che avete appena ascoltato
era Caruso di Lucio Dalla,
che è uno dei brani
che ho suonato il 2 giugno.
C'è ancora questo piccolo sol.
È già stato detto tutto prima,
quindi questa era una delle canzoni
che ho suonato il 2 giugno,
quindi quasi un anno fa:
oggi è il 30 di maggio,
e sono successe tante cose quest'anno,
l'anno scorso e quest'anno.
Questa è la mia seconda tournée,
che sta iniziando proprio adesso.
Innanzitutto, è un piacere essere qui
a fare questo micro-concerto,
all'interno di questo evento
molto importante.
Quest'estate avrò una quarantina
di concerti, un po' in tutta Italia.
Proprio 10 giorni fa ero a Milano,
a fare un concerto
all'interno di Piano City
insieme al mio artista preferito,
che si chiama Oren Lavie,
cantautore israeliano,
che ha scritto il prossimo pezzo
che vi farò ascoltare.
Questa è "A Quarter Past Wonderful"
(Musica)
Potete battere le mani.
Too late, somehow.
It's a quarter past wonderful, now.
And I say, what have we done to ourselves?
I mean, what have we done?
Got nothing new,
telling me, telling you.
And the sky isn't blue
like the blue that we knew.
Don't know how,
but that something extra delicious,
something sweet but nutritious,
something good.
But I guess that we blew it,
I mean I guess that we knew it,
I mean I guess that we did.
Don't ask me how,
it's a quarter past wonderful now.
And I say, what have we done to ourselves?
I mean, what have we done?
Got nothing new, telling me, telling you,
and the sky, which was clear,
it is no longer here.
Don't know how,
but that something extra delicious,
something sweet but nutritious,
something good.
But I guess that we blew it,
I mean I guess that we knew it,
I mean I guess that we did.
Don't know how,
but that something extra delicious,
something sweet but nutritious,
something good.
But I guess that we blew it,
I mean I guess that we knew it,
I mean I guess that we did,
I mean I guess that we -
did.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
(Musica)
Bene, nel frattempo il sol -
No, è ancora qui,
non ci ha ancora salutato.
Forse mi sta dicendo
che dovrei fare un pezzo in sol.
In realtà ne sto per fare
uno in sol diesis,
però vabbè, è un pezzo mio,
di cui io ho scritto la musica,
e il testo è di Benedetta Marianelli,
una mia amica di Pisa.
Sono anch'io di Pisa.
Non so se ho l'accento un po' pisano,
o forse con qualche
contaminazione milanese,
perché ormai son sempre qua,
però non lo so.
Questa si intitola "I'll miss you".
(Musica)
I listen to the sound of your solitude.
Feel like a lighter in the ocean.
You're my everyday illusion,
and I'm running from my uprise faith.
I'm breaking on the same land
that I've already seen.
I'll miss you, I'll miss you,
down this road.
just walking alone.
Just seeing in front of regrets now...
and destinations.
I chose to enter your labyrinth,
then realized you were a monster.
To play at your same game
without referee, without rules,
and I'll miss the dancing
through your eyes.
Your lullabies in the night.
My undying smile.
I'll miss you, I'll miss you,
down this road.
just walking alone.
Just seeing in front of regrets now...
and destinations.
No destinations.
I'll miss you, I'll miss you,
down this road.
just walking alone.
Just seeing in front of regrets now...
and destinations.
No destinations.
No -
destinations.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
Mi sa che ne posso fare anche un'altra,
Anche un'altra, in sol!
(Applausi)
Questa di solito la faccio in sol bemolle,
ma penso che mi converrà
provare a trasporla in sol,
perché sento proprio
che ha proprio voglia, questo microfono
di farmi suonare un pezzo in sol.
Ci provo.
Per chi non lo sapesse,
prima dicevamo dell'orecchio assoluto.
L'orecchio assoluto
è quella cosa per cui -
Insomma, secondo me
è una questione di abitudine,
perché molti di noi ce l'hanno,
ma non sanno di averlo.
Tanti musicisti hanno tantissimo orecchio,
quasi assoluto.
Poi, ci sono coloro
che riconoscono le note.
Questa cosa penso
sia dovuta, nel mio caso,
a una persona qua presente,
che è mia mamma Petra Magoni,
che è dietro le quinte, un applauso.
Un, applauso!
Di solito, ai bambini
si spiegano i colori:
questo è rosso,
questo è giallo, questo è blu.
Lei, invece, si metteva al piano:
questo è un do, questo un re,
questo un mi, e così via.
Finché poi andavamo al supermercato
e io sentivo ovviamente la cassa.
"Questa è la cassa fa,
dov'è la cassa sol?"
E così via.
(Applausi)
Detto questo, questo brano
di Jacob Collier,
quindi neanche una cosa banale,
non l'ho mai suonato in sol,
ma visto che questo microfono
insiste proprio...
The sun is in your eyes.
Throw me the cold,
throw me the cold, cold water
of your smile again.
You take me by surprise,
you take me by surprise.
Throw me the bold,
throw me the bold, bold treasure
of your lips again.
And where I go
you'll lead me in the right direction.
With your love as my protection...
I'll be a world of your projection.
And where I go
singing songs of your affection
with rhymes to your perfection.
In my eyes, see your reflection...
of you.
I see it clearly now.
I'll hold you dearly now.
The sun is in...
my eyes.
Grazie.
(Applausi)